I think, you know, people like you,
who've got a big heart and a big brain and a good message and good values.
We need you to have more attention, bigger platforms, the people who are the,
the people who are really, I mean,
there are people in this world who are really just out for themselves or who
really just don't care or who actually just mean those people never shrink
from the opportunity to grab the microphone.
And so therefore I think it's important for other people to have an equal and
fair shot.
Well, for me, I'm just all about trying to get the job done.
I accomplished the goal. I mean, for us, it's like let's eradicate poverty,
let's put money into people's hands,
let's make it so that people have the opportunity to be time-starved and not
just starving.
And, and when you see those, you know, when you see those food lines,
now we have food lines in America,
people in their cars because of the virus and the economic crash people are in,
in, in their cars for two hours,
three hours trying to drive up to food pantries and food banks to get a little
bit of food. That's not going to work. Uh,
and you have ideas that can, that can eliminate all that. And, uh, you know,
and so I do think as well,
I think people can also tell when you stop being mission first and you start
being me first, then the, the, the,
the air comes out of the balloon pretty quickly anyway. And so, you know,
I would just tell any of your critics or whatever, Hey, just, you know,
just wash me, keep me honest and see how it works out.
Yeah. To me,
we just need to get the job done and whatever tools come my way to get the job
done. Like, I'm all for, like,
if someone who's been bashing me at a particular
point in time, then like comes around later. I'm just like, cool. Let's do it.
The same way. You know, w when I left the Obama white house under fire,
you know, and been such a radical firebrand in my twenties and thirties,
uh, I was considered a, uh, a left wing radical in the Bay area.
Now you have to work hard to distinguish yourself in the Bay area as a left
winger, but I did it. And, um, and then after I, and my son was born and, um,
I started, you know, trying to figure out more constructive ways to, um,
to be a part of the local political community. I wind up, um, doing this,
uh, uh, green jobs Corps, uh, in Oakland,
getting kids off the street corners and trying to put up solar panels,
Nancy Pelosi finds out about it.
I went up going to DC to talk about the program, to all of her people.
We get George W. Bush to sign a bill called the green jobs act of 2007,
uh, which, um, replicated my program across the country,
through the department of labor. The next year I wrote a book about it.
A book became a bestseller suddenly, you know,
I'm in the Obama white house and, you know,
working with an $80 billion budget, working with Joe Biden and, uh, you know,
a bunch of other people, Valerie Jarrett, uh, trying to get, you know,
the green part of the stimulus package to work and instantly the right says,
wait a minute, this guy's in the white house. It's like, you know, protester,
this guy who's like against the police and all this sort of stuff, you know,
instant firestorm.
And those days you couldn't be controversial and stay in the white house.
So I resigned, they didn't ask me to resign. I offered to resign. I resigned.
And, um, uh, and I took a lot of heat from conservatives here.
We are 10 years later, or, you know,
they're about some of those same people who had come after me so hard.
I work with all the time.